[musique]
Oh, ce sera fini dans environ 30 minutes.
Je pensais que c'était parce que je l'avais entendu aussi
Alors attendons 10 minutes, juste 10 minutes
Endurons, tiens bon pendant 10 minutes
Lâche prise et c'est fini, pense à ta famille
Que pensez-vous de mon fils maintenant ?
Penser à ma femme, penser à ma soeur
doit
[musique]
Je pense que tout le monde a travaillé dur
La lutte, pour être honnête, en Corée
Parce que c'est un sport impopulaire
Les femmes disent lutte ou maintenant
tome
Quel genre d'exercice faites-vous?
je lutte
Si vous demandez et répondez
Une femme qui lutte. Certains aiment ça.
C'est l'atmosphère, maintenant à travers le sac physique.
Qu'une femme lutte
C'est beaucoup connu, donc c'est vraiment
glorieux
[musique]